how do you inspire service in others or  for others to do service that's so  difficult I don't even know if I've  mastered that but on a daily basis it's  definitely being a leader that people  deserve my mom Way says if you capture  someone's heart you capture their mind  that sometimes it takes an emotional  connection in order to require it an  intellectual response or an intellectual  desire to respond indefinitely  and being able to connect emotionally is  really important I need to inspire them  or we all need to be inspired to do a  super tough task but we have emotional  compassion and love for one another so  it makes it okay